fait chaud attend on ne quitte pas c'est
que ça s'en va là ouais
[Musique]
pour l'ensemble du commerce français le
coc vide ça a été une grosse
perturbation pour le secteur alimentaire
ils s'en sont bien tirés mais beaucoup
beaucoup de casse dans le
non-alimentaire
[Musique]
leclerc et je crois système u et
carrefour aussi ont fait savoir au
premier ministre on était prêt à vendre
des autotests c'est curieux parce que
tous les autorités sanitaires disent
qu'il faudrait que qu'ils prolifèrent
mais nous n'avons pas encore le droit je
ne sais pas pourquoi aujourd'hui un
fleuriste n'a pas le droit de vendre des
fleurs mais il ya des rayons fleurs dans
les magasins de bricolage ou dans les
hypermarchés
on n'a pas le droit d'ouvrir un magasin
de bricolage mais si le magasin de
bricolage vend de la nourriture pour
animaux
alors il peut ouvrir ce rayon là c'est
vraiment le bordel pour qu'ils
travaillent en magasin de savoir ce qui
est autorisé à la vente et qui doit être
enrubanné pas beaucoup d'explications
pas beaucoup de justification nous on
sait que ces politiques et que c'est
pour éviter les querelles entre
commerçants mais quand on est sur le
terrain c'est sûr que la communication
gouvernementale là et pas très riche
quoi
[Musique]
je suis contre l'obligation d'un pass
sanitaire en plus qui seraient demandés
par des opérateurs privés commerçants
aux restaurateurs
après je me fais pas d'illusion chaque
pays va exiger de celui qui le
traversent d'être vaccinées dont quelque
part ce sera consigné si ce n'est dans
un pass ce sera dans un papier de doctor
who une application
le finistère est un des départements les
moins touchées c'est parce que le vent
qui souffle et purificateur sain et
joyeux
[Musique]
je suis très fier que le variant breton
n'est pas fait recette
il ya des moments où des brevets rond
sans passerelle
[Musique]
certains musées ont proposé à des
magasins comme à pau et à tarbes
l'occurrence des centres leclerc
d'exposer des photos moi j'ai très hâte
à la réouverture de nos musées de
province franchement y'a rien qui ne
s'oppose à ce que des des musées qui
respecte des jauges puisse accueillir le
dimanche du grand public et leur offrir
comme ça une autre possibilité d'être
même en famille espacées et d'accéder à
la culture
[Musique]